David, what did you come up with?
>> From the beginning,
we start with A or something.
So as long as A is true,
then we know the result is true.
We don't even care about the rest of it.
When A is false,
then we need to look at B and the not C.
Because this is an and, we need
both B and not C to both be true.
So, when B is false, we can go ahead and
say this is false over here.
And when not C is false, we can go
ahead and say this is false over here.
Not C is false, if C is true,
so this is also false.
So, our only other answer that's
true is that row right there.
>> So, as you can see, this can
become very complicated very quickly.
But David did get the answer to the
truth value of this particular sentence,
based on the truth
values of the predicates
that are inside the sentences.
So in principle now, we can see how we
can compute the truth value of very,
very complicated sentences
returning logic.